[Música]
em 2012 e morava no rio tinha emprego
considerado por muito perfeito mas meu
senso de propósito me cobrava todo dia
não estava feliz
se um vazio que precisava ser preenchido
eu sentia mas não sabe exatamente o que
é esse vazio nessa época surgiu aqui em
recife diversos movimentos sociais
o e se vence sair às ruas para se
apropriar da cidade e era a primeira vez
que eu via isso acontecer com tamanha
intensidade
um dia eu acordei com a seguinte notícia
mais de 20 mil pessoas se aglutinavam no
bairro de santo antônio um para reclamar
por uma ocupação mais democrática da
cidade
lindo demais ver essa mudança de atitude
nos meus conterrâneos e aí eu tive um
estalo
eu entendi que eu precisava estar aqui e
fazer parte disso precisava retribuir
por tudo aquilo que eu tinha construído
pra mim e aí sem pensar muito voltei
chegando aqui a primeira coisa que eu
fiz foi procurar por pessoas que tinham
essa mesma vontade de alguma forma
contribuir com a mudança uma
transformação da realidade do nosso país
e para minha surpresa e aí grata
surpresa
rapidamente um grupo se formou
nós nos encontrávamos sistematicamente
para discutir planejar e realizar ações
também achamos importante conversar com
pessoas
fomos à prefeitura conversamos com
empresários fomos até diversas
comunidades falamos com líderes
comunitários cidadãos comuns
alunos professores e nesse processo uma
questão muito importante veio à tona o
que a gente chama de síndrome de
transferência da responsabilidade
você deve estar se perguntando aí sim de
1 mil que
parece complicado mas a simples a gente
entender o que para a grande maioria dos
brasileiros
existe sempre um terceiro uma pessoa um
agente externo quer é responsável pelos
problemas instalados em geral o
brasileiro não se vê como agente de
mudança e isso nos uniu em definitivo
para de alguma forma buscar alguma
alternativa que pudesse contribuir para
que o brasileiro se sente se responsável
pela mudança que a gente tanto deseja
um exemplo de como isso acontece na
prática quem aqui conhece uma pessoa que
vive reclamando do governo mas não sabem
em quem votou na última eleição também
tem outro exemplo clássico
aquela pessoa que diz eu repudio
corrupção não fala em corrupção perto de
mim mas aí quando você vai ver fura fila
de banco paga propina à guarda de
trânsito
qualquer oportunidade que tem sonega
impostos tem também aquele cidadão que
diz o seguinte a eu trabalho demais meu
chefe não me reconhece isso é um absurdo
e aí quando a gente chega perto e vai
investigar
vira e mexe e inventa doença na sexta
feira para ter aquele final de semana
prolongado
eu acabei de acabou de ocorrer um outro
exemplo tem gente que diz assim também
você acha certo estacionar na calçada há
pessoas assim acho que não mas é só um
minutinho que eu vou deixar meu filho na
escola francisco então iguais a estes a
gente tem muitos exemplos uma centena
talvez até milhares de exemplos e muita
gente acha graça até acho que é
inofensivo faz parte do nosso jeitinho
brasileiro a gente não nós
esse grupo que se formou acha que essa
falta de atitude para pode arruinar o
nosso país e é para isso que a gente
está trabalhando a gente acredita que a
mudança só será relevante quando ela
começará em cada indivíduo
e a gente foi no mundo buscar o que é
que poderia trazer esse senso de
responsabilidade para as pessoas
desde o começo era óbvio pra gente que
não haveria mudança definitiva sem que
houvesse uma reviravolta na educação
nosso sistema educacional que deveria
está formando nossas crianças e jovens
para o futuro é antiquado e não gera os
resultados que deveria estar gerando e
aí para dimensionar o que eu tô falando
eu trouxe pra vocês esse estudo que
upson encomendou a economist
intelligence unit instituto de pesquisa
vinculado ao the economist que colocou o
brasil como antepenúltimo em comparação
à educação de países economicamente
relevante é triste como desejar mudança
esse ambiente que a escola que está
formando nossos cidadãos do futuro tá
dessa forma
e foi por isso que nós esse grupo
mergulhou nessa questão para procurar
alternativas que pudessem dar uma mexida
nisso que pudessem transformar essa
realidade
e aí saindo desse mergulho de uma visita
tudo o que estava sendo feito no mundo e
iniciativas diversas e até em outras
áreas também
a gente começou a se perguntar e se a
gente desce uma mexida na atitude dessa
garotada e com uma atitude a gente
entende exatamente o ato de assumir
responsabilidade pela própria vida e em
busca do que a gente deseja
independente do que seja e aí a gente
começou a entrar mais ainda nessa nesse
questionamento ehf ao invés da gente em
ensinar disciplinas a gente desenvolver
competências a gente desenvolver se a
liderança a gente desenvolver se a
sociabilidade a gente desenvolver o
domínio
metodológicos o domínio das ferramentas
técnicas
esse agente estimulasse o pensamento
crítico quebrasse um pouco esse
paradigma do pará do decoreba para a
prova que está tão instalado nas nossas
escolas
e se a gente criar se uma fábrica de
sonhos dentro das escolas
desce a cada um dos alunos que está lá
dentro uma perspectiva de futuro
brilhante sem estereótipos e se a gente
explicar se pra eles que não tem nada de
errado colocar a mão na massa
acabou essa história de que só pensar é
nobre que fazer não é nobre fazer é
nobre sim ea união entre pensar e fazer
é que vai gerar resultados grandiosos e
aí depois de toda essa esse mergulho
nessas questões
emergiu pra gente a necessidade de ok a
gente tem aí possibilidades mil mas a
gente precisa comprovar que essas
possibilidades já eram de fato algum
resultado que essas possibilidades
trazem a educação uma alternativa e pra
isso a gente conduziu um projeto piloto
em duas escolas estaduais com 60 alunos
a primeira escola a escola se jungthon
çalves que fica no entorno do centro da
região metropolitana ao redor da escola
é duas favelas perigosíssimas o
dia-a-dia assolado pela questão da
violência doméstica e pelo narcotráfico
com os professores numa situação muito
difícil porque os alunos são
extremamente indisciplinadas a
infraestrutura precária gerando
inclusive perigo eminente a qualquer
momento poderia acontecer alguma coisa e
hoje estou descrente sem saber o que
poderia fazer
a situação era calamitante quando nós
chegamos a essa escola rapidamente
identificamos que existe um gap muito
grande de desenvolvimento da liderança e
da sociabilidade o que era natural
considerando que a violência estava tão
instalada a outra escola a porto digital
que fica no centro do recife é uma
realidade completamente diferente também
estadual porém de referência era
organizadíssima a infraestrutura
impecável tudo no lugar
bancas novas merenda boa professores bem
preparados
o gestor no controle a situação era
melhor do que em muitas escolas
particulares que eu já visitei mas aí
nós conseguimos 20 identificar um outro
problema bem diferente das costas de
nuno gonçalves os alunos chegavam e
simplesmente cumpriu o protocolo
eles estavam comprometidos com
resultados medianos faltava atitude
faltava vontade de criar aquela escola
junto com os professores e com gestores
e aí por esse motivo inclusive eles
entraram um pouco de salto alto no
programa toda essa dinâmica que eu falei
pra vocês
ela acontece em dois momentos um momento
presencial onde a gente faz diversas
seções atividades e jogos com essa
garotada para tirar ele da zona de
conforto da uma chacoalhada e colocar e
leasing movimento você pode agora vai ea
gente vai te acompanhar isso dura um mês
e um segundo momento onde eles passam a
fazer uma parte de uma rede e nessa rede
estão outros alunos de outros programas
professores gestores pessoas no mercado
e nem tores que vão ajudar eles nesse
processo de desenvolvimento e esse dura
11 meses
ao final de um ano
nós que vivemos essa lente resultados
mas mais do que dizer pra vocês que a
escola conseguiu desenvolver a
competência tal ou a escola b conseguiu
desenvolver a outra competência eu tô
aqui pra dizer pra vocês
outra coisa primeiro nós conseguimos
medir as competências
então hoje o programa consegue dizer que
uma escola além de ter deficiências numa
determinada competência ela gerou
determinados resultados daquelas
competências em segundo e o que é mais
incrível
ambas as escolas de realidades tão
distintas uma com uma realidade
extremamente vulnerável e outra com uma
realidade tão organizada que tiveram
resultados muito semelhante
vocês já imaginaram como isso é uma
quebra de paradigma e como isso pode
mudar a educação pois é pra dá a
dimensão do que eu estou falando a gente
trouxe pra vocês dois depoimentos que
nos comovem muito primeiro do alan o
alan está aqui com a gente levanta pra
gente ir a uma lan vai o alan o alan ele
chegou ele é brilhante extremamente
talentoso desde o começo era
diferenciado em relação aos outros
alunos
mas chegou o programa acanhado ainda
pouco desenvolvido junto à chapa que não
podia participar de determinadas rotinas
e aí no final do processo ele traz o
seguinte depoimento para a gente hoje
independente da situação eu acredito que
eu posso
chego e fácil não espero que dêem o
primeiro passo por mim
isso mudou minha vida de diversas
maneiras conseguir um emprego
antes da maioridade porque descobri que
isso era possível
estou me envolvendo com inovação com
startup e além disso quero estudar e
trabalhar com design thinking coisas que
achava que achava que estavam distantes
de mim mas que agora vejo que possa
alcançar
então essa é a mudança que a gente
deseja para todo e qualquer aluno que
está na nossa escola e também quero
trazer para vocês o depoimento da
professora renata
a professora renata também está por aqui
no seio daquela tá bom eu estou
conseguindo achar professora renata mas
onde quer que você esteja renata saiba
que foi uma honra dividir sala de aula
com você
a professora renata trouxe pra gente o
seguinte depoimento
um dia eu cheguei na sala de aula e como
sempre na escola complicada o aluno
entrou com um skate e atrapalhou a minha
aula eu ensino física já tinha uma
dificuldade muito grande de conseguir
engajar os alunos
pensei vou demonstrar uma atitude
diferente
vou usar o que vocês me ensinaram nas
dinâmicas de treinamento para os
professores e vou utilizar essa entrada
de skate na sala de aula para explicar
as leis da física e aí ela disse pra
gente eu não consigo acreditar nos
resultados
consegui criar uma ponte com esses
alunos usando essa situação e pela
primeira vez eu me sinto útil
vocês já imaginaram como deve ser
difícil para um professor que está ali
querendo mudar a nossa realidade se
sente inútil
então é isso que a gente deseja a gente
deseja mudar a escola e forma sistêmica
trazendo uma oportunidade para os alunos
mas também trazendo uma mudança os
professores para os gestores para a
comunidade e para todo mundo que
freqüenta a escola e dessa forma se
concretizou o aik mm que essa idéia que
complementa a formação regular de
crianças e jovens do ensino fundamental
e médio
desenvolvendo nelas competências para a
vida que serviram independente da
profissão que elas escolherem a gente
acredita que eu
alan renata meus colegas estamos
começando uma revolução de baixo para
cima
o que vai mudar o brasil através da
escola e uma mudança na escola através
da atitude a gente ainda não sabe
exatamente quais vão ser os resultados
mas nós vamos lutar incansavelmente para
criar uma alternativa e fazer uma
contribuição que o futuro é o seguinte
em janeiro nós vamos está rodando um
novo ciclo do projeto em 360 jovens que
estarão assumindo a responsabilidade
pela própria vida e começando a aumentar
essa legião de transformadores que vamos
a ajudar a alcançar essa tão desejada
mudança
isso nos dá esperança mas essa esperança
ela também reside em cada um de vocês
que se agora fizerem uma reflexão e
entenderem que podem independente da
causa se movimentarem para mudar a
realidade que vocês estão vivendo vão
criar pra gente um futuro brilhante
obrigado
[Aplausos]